au duke duke katyn et paco khatib a
piqué une crise va voir sa cathy eva fip
est grave quand elle va voir que que tu
as semé la pagaille est passée juste
enfin c'est juste un vase tiens vase
duke un bel os mais c'est terrible tu
fais quoi là
ce que moi je fais rien je dis je suis
un bon toutou très gentil jeu cathy
c'est que je ne ferais jamais une chose
dans ce genre
non non ça ne peut être l'oeuvre que
d'un dangereux chiens errants s'il n'a
pas encore établi de relation de
confiance
tu es le nouveau venu et mme ndiouck
pourquoi tu fais sort soit fait quoi en
quoi tu veux me croquer me dévorer tout
cru
la phase i et attend que katia traîne ça
au secours makati au point tu es rentré
j'ai essayé de l'arrêter mais mais c'est
un vrai malade maintenant à six